Eh, still.
>> Dana: THE FDA WARNING OF A
POSSIBLE LINK BETWEEN THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON COVID VACCINE
AND A RARE AUTOIMMUNE NERVE
DISORDER.
THE FDA IS REPORTING 100 CASES
OF THE RARE DISORDER OF 12.5
MILLION PEOPLE WHO GOT THE SHOT.
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
TELL US WHAT IS THE RATE OF
RISK HERE WHEN YOU WEIGH
GETTING THE VAC MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE GOTTEN THE J&J SHOT BUT
ONLY 5 MILLION SINCE APRIL WITH
THE SCARE ABOUT BLOOD CLOTS.
100 CASES LINKED TO THE VACCINE
OUT OF A TOTAL OF 13 MILLION.
SO IT IS EXTREMELY RARE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT COVID
ITSELF GIVES YOU THIS
AUTOIMMUNE CONDITION WHERE
LITERALLY YOU GET WEAKNESS AND
SOME LOSS OF SENSATION.
ALMOST ALWAYS TEMPORARY, BY THE
WAY.
IT IS SCARY WHEN YOU HAVE IT
BUT ALMOST ALWAYS TEMPORARY.
SO I DON’T THINK THIS IS A
REASON NOT TO TAKE THE J&J SHOT
BUT ONLY ABOUT 8% OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TAKEN THE VACCINE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON THE J&J
BECAUSE THEY WANT ONE AND DONE.
MOST HAVE BEEN THE PFIZER AND
MODERNA SHOTS.
I DON’T WANT IT TO CONTRIBUTE
THE VACCINE HESITANCY.
DELTA VARIANT IS GOING THROUGH
THE UNVACCINATED PEOPLE.
YOU CAN GET IT FROM COMMON
BACTERIA, 10 IN A MILLION CASES
OF THIS SYNDROME AS IT IS.
THIS DOESN’T CHANGE THE
EQUATION FOR THE J&J SHOT,
THOUGH IT WILL CLEARLY CHANGE
PUBLIC PERCEPTION.
>> Bill: THAT WAS MY QUESTION.
YOU STILL RECOMMEND GETTING THE
SHOT.
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND IT FOR
EVERYONE OR IS THERE ANY
MEDICAL OR PHYSICAL INDICATOR
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL PERSON THAT
MIGHT GIVE THEM A WARNING
BEFORE IF THEY WERE SUSCEPTIBLE
PERHAPS TO THIS NERVOUS
CONDITION?
>> THAT’S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
HAD IT BEFORE I WOULDN’T
RECOMMEND THIS SHOT.
WE’VE SEEN THIS ASSOCIATE WITH
FLU SHOTS AND SHINGLES SHOTS.
IT IS A CONDITION WE SEE
ASSOCIATED WITH VIRUSES,
BACTERIA AND VACCINES BUT SO
THIS WOULDN’T CHANGE ME.
I WANT EVERYONE OUT THERE TO
KNOW IF YOU HAD THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON SHOT AND YOU DIDN’T
HAVE A COMPLICATION, YOU WON’T